[Music]
in cop compensation news that's three
times really salvation cop cause of
things like conversation I said really
fat I did faster
topics cop comes with a stopped
opposition as I was always pretty good
yes I submitted my parts parts no it has
a soul of its own when it came from the
dimension of death a police officer is
awarded fifteen thousand dollars in
damages after being bitten by a flea
while on duty
oh we've bitten file please you got
assaulted by a flea during the line of
duty huh so how much you get paid from
mosquito bite then put the food again
I'd be a millionaire pause a cop I just
ate all the mosquito infested Oh Bobo
Bobo
that's $100 like that do please carry
diseases systems I mentioned you do
Halloween why me yeah scary then
Lyme diseases mine this will actually
like he got shot during [ __ ] absent
or cool people I went to go [ __ ]
catch a stray dog and I got bit by a
sleepy yeah so it takes place in the UK
and there was an unnamed cop course he
was his roommate fifteen thousand seven
hundred and thirty eight dollars or
twelve thousand one hundred twenty seven
British pounds in damages after he's sue
damages he sued the police Wow
and so he got a compensation payout and
so that he also made the police pay for
his legal fees which was five thousand
four hundred thirty one dollars and
sixty cents so you don't bite the hand
that feeds you exactly not its context
exactly I think this article saying that
they've just been having a lot of wort
cop cases especially with the police
officers and that it sucks because the
taxpayers have to pay these like
ridiculous amounts that they're claiming
for they do have like an insurance
company that looks into it and then they
determine how much these cops need to
get paid for compensation but to me
personally this seems kind of ridiculous
why did they deserve compensation from
getting bit by
sweet yeah can we explain that case yeah
what are they suing under yeah how do
they prove that it happened on the duty
here's how I could see it okay let's say
they had a dirty-ass police car and they
had these pack of dogs that they put in
there and it's just [ __ ] full of
ticks and fleas and they never took care
of it and the department's being a
cheap-ass and every time someone sits in
there you get a bunch of herpes on your
ass because all the fleas and STDs that
[Laughter]
is going but because of the negligence
and cleanse the hygiene levels and
everything is not up to par you know
this guys always get bit on the ass by
the fleet and he's like you know what
I'm tired of this [ __ ] no more fleas and
then he [ __ ] went for it wouldn't
that be cool that would make sense under
what grounds did you do it
they don't elaborate the whole suite
think the only thing that they the only
information they give us is the fact
that he got bitten while on duty and
that it that flea bite resulted in
emergency surgery whoa whoa [ __ ] Oh
article how you going to go into surgery
for most three but is he allergic to
fleas
I don't know beautiful me that's all
really bright and fall if I got stung by
a bee and I thought I'm allergic
then I might die that's my fault yeah so
why should you get compensated hi
reverse that whatever zone I'm trying to
help you out cop I just don't get it
yeah and they're they're also saying
like former police officers are saying
that the whole compensation culture is
just way too common now that has gotten
way too soft like one police officer was
like you know why I was a policeman for
twenty years and I can't even imagine
what would happen if I were to gone to
my senior officer and started moaning
because I had been bitten by a bleep
dope because they're making fun of us
like Loki they're making fun of us
because we became a crazy-ass soup of
[ __ ] culture require everything so
this is in the UK right yeah are these
officers of them the
Oh generation I don't know sounds like
it I could totally see my fellow
Millennials going out there and saying
I'm not going to work because I got
injured in the line of duty
I deserve a Purple Heart it's [ __ ]
free baby yeah I could be saying
continues I would have been kicked out
of the office at the clipping
around-the-ear I thought I've been told
to get back to doing my job there's no
way they would have allowed that times
are a bit hard still and have to be and
to have the audacity to make a claim
that on taxpayers money is extraordinary
so he's like it's gone soft all I can
say is that I'm glad that I've retired
compensation culture it's ripe across
too many forces in this country like
it's just going to drain the state bank
accounts so since these cases are common
like you know any of them well there are
some other ones that they mentioned too
like for example one officer who tripped
at work was given t mints in excess of
six thousand four hundred eighty nine
dollars and forty eight cents for
trippin for tripping Tripp it all what
the [ __ ] is crazy I don't know the full
details of fees Wow two cops were
injured due to manual handling and they
were given like a manual book they
display in quotations like a wrestling
match with like a criminal or something
I don't know to me it sounded more like
it was maybe we should I be I don't know
this is crazy
well yeah one of them I've paid seven
thousand seven hundred eighty seven
thirty-seven cents the other one 11100
2004 is tripping this is the manual
handling this was a lot of money running
another one was handed nine thousand
four hundred forty dollars which is
conversation support let's use defective
equipment use while on the job so that
one's like okay fine he has the real it
all these are on in the line of duty I'm
assuming a big coppers yes officers so
they're just saying that they it's like
a range of bizarre workplace injuries
and you win so from between April 1st
last year in March 31st the force paid
seventy nine thousand three hundred and
thirty three dollars this is all us
always is think of us [ __ ] crazy yeah
in compensation for workplace maybe
there's more to the story that
we don't know about because for the
longest time I thought the lady that
sued McDonald's for spilled coffee was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] until you realize that
that should use so hot that it burned
elated her skin and you see pictures and
you go oh [ __ ] that really didn't [ __ ]
you up
and then she's the one that changed the
game and said now McDonald's you can't
make a coffee to hot coffees not hot
enough anymore
it's not good still really nice me too I
know I love hot things like I like it to
burn my mouth and then you know when the
top of your mouth it starts ripping with
the skin because it was so hot blister
that [ __ ] that's what I'm you can't take
it up like next two days can you [ __ ]
take about 30 G's you to learn how to
click with better learn chick and you
get burned over don't over it over you
got go comes to me all the time
clerk yeah gets in there and help cool
the liquid down and then use again yes I
still burn my tongue every single time
what I think you're doing the row are
you practicing every day though no see
you have practice every day no just
another Burton on my Devon I can't
tasting it really good because you
barely have to tip it see buddy and
that's all you need so that little thing
it works you ever tie doing is IV then
alternate let you hit the accelerator
tech boom [ __ ] you up why would you can
you're the one driving controlling it
happy shocking
you don't know Oh in the keys to blow as
you're going so you got it'll go as low
not like that cooling the top layer
yeah it's the top layer and then you
pull out the water it's like you're
chipping that Ice Cube so I'm just shoot
a National Geographic style video and
how you do that
it's all slo-mo and chances like I know
researching temperance I have my own
technique in the morning on some listen
to rush to make the hot ass coffee and I
go and I got the ice cube the throne
that can I take it that's how I drink my
coffee on time close it down right back
Gendry anything huh crazy technique it's
pretty people don't think the way I do
though
fine take it away I'm sure I'll leave it
out for like ice use Bionic the ice and
water
on the way census I don't want a doubt
it is one of them but you have your even
still waiting 15 minutes a genius Jamie
I want to sue someone no because Larry
American of you I never I never shoot
anyone
and that's pretty normal no like it's
not like if if I I should probably take
advantage of people a little bit more
like I mean look at all these people
that are winning you know like some
people they work all their lives you
work really really hard and then like
you know you you finally get the fruits
of your labor but there's people out
there that are really taking charge and
then and just exploiting people like
real fast and they win it's a character
type I feel like those people all have
like this like to play victim like that
it didn't character type to play victim
all the time so many when they come
across a situation that they you know
they're in there like a complete victim
right now Oh next that I've spoken to
this like yeah advance paddle towing
kind of exactly and I think for for us
to I don't think we have that play they
threaten to sue you don't think you hear
people to the wall sue you you watch out
like well my dad's a lawyer or like my
friend to Laura like just we left threat
threatened with the law I've never done
that before I can never see you do that
yeah that's like what's a [ __ ] really
given grab her face and smashes into our
window before you ever say yeah because
I'm scholarly in not boil time at the
restaurant that I was working out where
there's his old lady those up at this a
buffet bar getting her food and she
actually slits fool and then her family
member actually came up to her and just
checking on her to make sure she's okay
and we had like one of our employees go
up and see if they're okay as they
needed like assistance or anything doing
no no like we're good we're fine right
the next week like they there's actually
like a lawyer like sending in like a
lawsuit thing like oh you know like your
floors were slippery that's why you know
like my grandma like tripped and fell
but then there was just like we we saw
our CCTV the floor was clean there was
no puddles on it you can see like the
Sally member and our employee
immediately assisting and then you can
see them suing the motions of oh no no
no we don't need help so it's just kind
of like their case was
debunked because of that but it sucks
that you guys even have to get bothered
by something like that it's stressful
and it causes anxiety at work and I want
that off [ __ ] what's what's gonna happen
to the business unnecessary stress I
remember when I worked at a restaurant
and we were close enough and we were
like mopping the floor we didn't put
that like wet sign up and the reason
Mahalo yeah and then like there was
these drunk guys and it were like
thinking why don't we just wet it up
extra hard
they're [ __ ] annoying and drunk so we
did that and then they all just slipped
and fell and slammed their backs and
[ __ ] and we were just cracking the [ __ ]
up were they laughing or not nah you're
hurt they're just like oh no they're too
drunk
they were like way too wasted they were
walking to the bathroom yeah we're there
to wases I feel the pain or they know
they were hurt we just slipped and both
and it 100 had like these like snakeskin
cowboy boots or some [ __ ]
that's liberal yeah all you see is this
like cowboy with it's like boots and the
efforts in like ah you're evil I can sue
no they're just like Oh what and like I
think when they're drunk they don't know
that that's that they can feel yeah but
we we did that you know a lot about the
system they stay aware to sue they was
through the restaurant yeah I know I
don't give a [ __ ] about that restaurant
- that's a two three two or three to
underfund a three single [ __ ] guys I
like to have anything is a three single
[ __ ] hope you guys enjoyed that video
if you did a really cool way to
communicate that to us and for you to
never miss another video is by
subscribing so click on that little
subscribe button and you'll never miss
an episode for the next episode click
right up here
[Music]